former head of the british army lord
danette lord dana lovely to see you this
morning um
a year on from the fall of kabul um the
home secretary pretty patel has has been
expressing her tremendous pride about
the government's afghanistan
government's evacuation did you share in
that pride with the benefit of of course
of hindsight
well um
i've got huge pride
in the way that the soldiers that we
sent to kabul uh carried out their
duties in what was undeniably a chaotic
situation
yes we managed to get quite a number of
entitled people out but we left a
tremendous number of people there but
you know neil this begs a whole wider
question
why did that happen why would those
circumstances allowed to take place
frankly
i believed at the time it was
unnecessary a year later it was
unnecessary and as your report has shown
afghanistan is in terrible condition at
the present moment
and if we reflect on why we spent 20
years in afghanistan
yes we achieved what we originally
wanted to achieve which was to contain
al-qaeda so they couldn't carry out more
attacks in the west but most
particularly we spent those 20 years
building up afghan society giving afghan
society afghan people
a future and some hope
and it is therefore tragic
that we quite unnecessarily withdrew in
precipitate haste
a year ago
but then i think absolutely outrageously
have cut aid to afghanistan such that
the people
the babies around the condition that
your film has just shown
right across the country people are
starving we went there to help the
afghan people and now we're just
actually watching them suffer i think
it's outrageous and i think
pretty patel and other members of the
government should take no pride in what
is happening there they should be
starting again as should the americans
who are principally responsible for what
happened should be significantly
increasing their aid packages again to
allow the people to to have food and to
thrive in afghanistan and not to have
television films such as you've shown
everybody showing what pitiful condition
that they are in um is there pride yes
pride in our soldiers is there pride in
what our government and international
governments are doing not at all
yeah i'm watching stuart's report this
morning before coming on the program
it's difficult not to to have been moved
by but just talk a little bit more then
about your experience in country the the
assistance that the british did give
during that 20-year period i was on the
ground a few times with with british
forces saw the hearts and minds efforts
saw the education of children in a way
which hadn't had never been done before
all of that progress it would seem has
now been rolled back by a taliban that
resembles the taliban of 2001.
yes i think we all have to acknowledge
that the taliban are repressive but
again it comes back to the question um
we went to afghanistan to help the
people of afghanistan now we're making
films watching the people of afghanistan
suffer yes we may not like the taliban
we may not like their attitude i
certainly don't towards women and girls
and stopping girls getting to secondary
education but
just because we don't like their human
rights record and of course it's a big
issue but because we don't like their
human rights record and the number of
things that they're doing we're
withholding aid from the people of that
country such that babies are dying
people are starving and
it's not for want of food in the country
it's for want of money to be able to buy
it we have starved the place of cash
in an economy that was made up by about
80 percent of international aid forming
the cash flow of that country so we
could change this we could stop this we
actually could help the people of
afghanistan and i believe that um
diplomats and statesmen should be
thinking seriously about starting aid
again to afghanistan and using that aid
to leverage
on the taliban to get them to change
some of the
attitudes that they take particularly
towards women and girls and girls
secondary education
just to be clear though about what
you're saying there lord danette i mean
given the fact that 60 of of afghanistan
is currently suffering from malnutrition
their gold reserves are still frozen
there has been a stop to aid i mean are
we in the west then essentially
responsible perhaps even more
responsible than the taliban for what
stewart was seeing in the hospitals
well put it bluntly
the american decision initially by
donald trump and then agreed by joe
biden
that the americans would leave
afghanistan by august last year which
was a unilateral decision about which we
were not consulted and other partners
were not consulted that decision
directly led to the collapse of the
afghan national army the afghan national
police and allowed the taliban to take
over the country
that having happened
the west has said we don't like the
taliban so we're going to cut off aid to
this country and having cut off aid to
afghanistan that is why babies are dying
in hospitals that is why people are
starving up and down the country now
is that right
as i said before and we spent 20 years
building up
afghanistan afghanistan society we spent
20 years helping the people why should
we suddenly stop helping the people now
because we don't like the taliban
frankly
yes their human rights record is not
good they have stopped second girls
going to secondary school but is that
the right price to pay for the majority
of afghan people to be starving and
babies to be dying i don't think so i
think we've got this terribly wrong and
governments need to wake up start the
flow of aid again and
give the afghan people for whom we tried
to help them for 20 years give them the
prospect of a future while bearing down
on the taliban to say come on you
actually got to behave like a civilized
country a civilized government or
otherwise um you'll never take your
proper place in the world
it's part of the situation that we're
seeing at the moment perhaps that much
that many of the world's eyes are
elsewhere in fact afghanistan is a topic
rarely discussed around the dinner
tables these days i mean last august you
were speaking to us on the channel you
said something terrible will happen
elsewhere the world's media will move on
and this is when the taliban will
enforce their harsh regime i mean did
that happen in terms of ukraine
well of course it did um the disasters
emergency committee for example launched
an appeal this time last year to raise
funds for afghanistan but quite quickly
come february this year
they launched an appeal for ukraine and
that
raised over 300 million pounds um
and it's not as if it's ukraine that's
actually pushed afghanistan off the news
now the cost of living crisis and the
and the energy uh cost increases have
always pushed ukraine off the news we
are very short-termist in terms of our
of our intervention and it comes back to
my basic point we spent 20 years trying
to build up afghan society and help
afghan people why do we walk away now
and watch films a year on such as the
one that you're showing people this
morning of babies dying and people
starving frankly we've got to be
prepared to have longer engagements in
this country if we think human life is
worth preserving otherwise we'll just
watch them all perish